even though I know that I have 100
support from mckelty I know that she
also supports Robin 100 percent she can
balance like nobody I I know I'm so glad
you came to see us I'm glad he came to
you right that is nice with with like
everything going on with your mom and
stuff like that I just appreciate you
coming yeah of course I just want to
make sure that no matter what's
happening
uh there
you're still mom Robin and Grandma so
like that's my biggest thing is just
making sure that like
we're all good we our relationship
continues and it's based on what goes on
in our relationship that's not based on
outside sources it feels like
everything's uh affected my relationship
with everybody though
when it comes to you know like raising
kids and dealing with things like this
I'm I'm almost always bad cop and so my
relationship I feel like is somewhat
strained with a lot of my kids
hey
so are you doing okay yeah as far as
your mom and everything I mean I think
the situation around it is it's it's sad
I think it's sad anytime any kind of
family breaks up or separates yeah but
if it's what she wants I think it's
important to support what she wants
how long have you guys known
um I think that we as like known
actually it's been
I mean like is was she talking about it
before
she was talking about it she's been
talking about it for a while but I think
most of what she's been talking about is
what anybody talks about in a
relationship the ups and the Downs the
highs and the lows
I I know that I can't talk Christine to
my kids I don't want to talk her at all
even though that's my natural my natural
urge is to do that I have to control
that because that's not fair
catching myself in this moment here when
I'm saying how long have you guys known
and that's a blame game that I'm playing
and I feel ashamed that I'm doing that
but in my brokenhearted State the anger
is just flowing here and nobody likes me
[Music]